hello everyone welcome to another wolf
language design review session part of
our language completeness and
consistency series and we have a few
topics here today
replace plus Association
okay what is this story
so this is uh somewhat complicated story
so we'll just have to start at the
beginning and go through that
right so some functions Force evaluation
when you in fact probably most functions
which operate on associations Force
evaluation so you see we map pound
squared and we get a goes to 2.
um
ao's to four we get a goes to four out
right
and on the right hand side of the second
thing because it's a delayed assignment
delayed rule we don't get evaluation
right
now because it's it's sort of forcing
evaluation when it work does this it'll
behave quite differently from
uh
you know functions working on a sort of
General Expressions right so in the
second area so let me understand this
let me understand if I take this okay
and I mapped the same thing onto a list
here
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna map it at
level two onto a list and lists are
already very different because uh it'll
apply to the Keys as well yeah I know so
how do I do this let me just do a list
of the values that would be the
analogous thing to an association right
yeah exactly we don't have the delayed
uh delayed rule here
I guess
maybe let's do a map out here okay
and then let's do a map at uh let's see
one comma two two comma two
can you just say all comma two but okay
yeah I probably can't say it will come
too
actually let me just do that just for
the sake of whatever
does it work I'm not sure if we that was
certainly on the roadmap yeah we did do
that from at that okay okay all right
okay fine
so this is consistent with that which
seems sensible to me
right
okay but it's actually forcing
evaluation right the way it normally
works is that you know
inserts the function and then lets
evaluation proceed so if you look at the
next pair of inputs you'll see
a difference
okay because the side effects are
different because in one case it just I
mean map normally just wraps F if I say
map F on to a b it just Maps the F onto
the A and B and then Returns the results
and then evaluative takes over correct
correct but the point is that if it were
holds complete of a comma B then it well
for f it's the same but if F was
supposed to evaluate then it's different
and then the key point is that
Association is hold all complete
yeah right
although I would argue that it is whole
or complete but like it kind of
shouldn't be or like it's kind of a
fiction that it is most of the time
go ahead sorry the association itself is
wrapped and hold complete and yet that
hold complete is powerless to stop this
evaluation from happening I think that's
the issue ah I see so it's not that the
fact that the association itself is hold
complete it's the fact that it's wrapped
and hold complete yeah and yet it still
evaluates rules I see yeah I see so it
doesn't need to be that way I mean the
point is you've encountered something
that's going to suppress evaluation
that's independent of whether it's a
rule or a rule delayed
but that information is not passed down
to the function that then goes and
applies the function to the association
so if that hold if if map encountered
whole the whole complete and passed that
recursively to itself
and then pass that information to the
function that Association apply uses
then it could override its own default
which is to check for a rule or a rule
delayed and always use the raw delayed
case
instead of determining it on the fly so
I think that's just
you said something Mark hold on you said
it Association apply so is that the an
internal function or an external yeah
it's an internal function that when it
sees an association is going to apply a
function to the to the value okay so
that's the forced evaluator that's
that's yes exactly exactly and and when
that sees that that makes a default
Choice it says is the rule a rule
delayed I guess I won't evaluate it's
context independent it just sees the
association it doesn't does exactly the
question of how it got there is
invisible to it exactly exactly so if
that information was propagated down and
passed into that function then it could
kind of override its own default
strategy okay do we care I mean so what
are these other examples here
go ahead
right so
um
right so for example
replace has never forced evaluation
sorry replace all has never forced
evaluation
um which is even inside an association
or not
correct so that's the you know others
respect to hold all complete so I guess
that you know that sort of those that
middle pair of inputs with the X integer
and the and the act just x blank right
you see the a 2 squared there rather
than
of four
um okay so hold on a second let's just
understand so
inside map
somehow this Association apply
thing is that being called by the
internal code of maps yeah
yes
do that replace doesn't do the analog of
that replace right
right
so
so is there a difference between why is
the the top one why does it matter
whether it says X underscore integer
right so in one case
it's right it doesn't match the
association so it goes inside and it's a
replacement to each element whereas in
the when it's just x blank it squares
the integer and then you know power is
rewriting the whole into the whole
association okay so that's recently
totally different yeah it's just doing
the association squared right
okay
right the first one is pretty confusing
though I mean that's like an accident of
the fact that Association is hold
complete
correct
and so I'm profoundly confused the first
one that it Burrows to the point where
it sees two it sees that that matches X
underscore integer but because
this is hold complete it does the
replacement as it would inside any held
expression but doesn't evaluate anything
correct right whereas in this case here
the X blank is matching the whole
association and it's just doing its
standard I'm I'm squaring my values yeah
yeah I mean there's a real question here
I mean the real weirdness is again just
a consequence of the fact that
associations hold all complete I mean
because of course if you if you do a
replace all over hold all complete you
know it's gonna behave like that where
you're gonna end up with a two squared
sure but if you do that on a list you're
not going to get a 2 squared it's going
to evaluate okay so it said Y is a very
different
behavioral complete
yeah
well it's I mean in the sense that's a
bit of a fiction but basically
associations as raw expressions are not
subject to infinite reevaluation
so what they pretend to be
you mean you mean I see the evaluator
itself
because it is a raw expression
as a matter of implementation the
evaluator is not recursively called
correct
so any evaluation that has to be done is
done by hand so to speak right and
that's what the association apply but so
the fact that it has the mark hold all
complete that's not the main point the
point is really that it's a raw
expression yeah right
whose behavior in the evaluator I mean
the evaluator
right now its behavior is if you see a
raw expression just ignore it
and anything that goes inside has to be
custom done for that type of raw
expression
but in principle the evaluator just like
the evaluator has cases for ordinary
expressions with different attributes
and so on the evaluator could have a
case for associations it just says go
inside and do your evaluation couldn't
it
well that's a question I guess that Mark
and Tom should opine on
I mean yes it could the question is
should it
right well my my next question is what
is the heinous thing that happens here
because I'm I'm worried that for example
Marx context carrying by map is just
another pump trying to keep the ship
from sinking then it's not going to you
know you just add more pumps it's not
going to work in the end to say let's
emulate something which is really an
evaluated change by something which just
involves you know particular cases now
having said that
you know the meta theorem is the only
evaluator that has no weird Behavior as
an evaluator that does nothing
so I don't think it's going to be the
case you know in other words we've got
some weird Corner cases here but that's
in compensation of the fact that most of
the time it does the right thing and the
question is should we worry about the
corner cases
I I think I have a bad feeling the
corner cases are unfixable
those we can we can you know fix a
particular corner but then there's going
to be another Corner that shows up and
so on
and the question is when do we stop
well I don't know I mean again the the
behavior is pretty well defined for
lists for example so I mean I feel like
it I don't really see why it would be
that fundamentally different with
associations other than just historical
implementation choices that were made
you know a decade ago
okay but
but all right so if we did an uh you
know like a list
if we thought that associations should
operate like lists does that resolve all
semantic questions or not
for example are the keys evaluated
um are the key basically our keys
evaluated
I don't even know
yeah that that is one of the that is one
of the issues sometimes the thinking of
associations it's like quote unquote
just like any other expression is that
Behavior like things like replace all
and expecting it to run the keys is kind
of unexpected but it's also kind of what
you want
right except that right in in a lot of
functions the keys are ignored right so
in the initial construction there right
the keys are
are evaluated because you know when
you're first constructing an association
it evaluates everything inside according
to normal rules but you know when you if
you map anything or you use replace any
replace function then it's going to
completely ignore the the keys
specifically yeah there are key
functions yeah but maybe maybe try try
if you say you know X if you make an
association with X as a key and then
Define X yeah exactly
yeah get evaluated
well you need to save that in a variable
or something but yeah and then you want
to get 13.
right but if you do that with a list
then the X would have evaluated
presumably so okay so this is a case
where we see the difference
yeah right only in the keys though
notably the values still behave just
like a list
okay is that true when it's um
okay actually sorry in this case they
they might not but they I would argue
that they in theory should
like like I think keys keys are a little
bit look look look look what just
happened there
so that actually didn't evaluate
no you have to do you you've got the
output you need to get the input
no it's kind of
quite often I said x equals nine
once the association is created it
doesn't evaluate don't tell me look look
if that was a list okay if I did the
same thing with a list
yeah well clearly yes right let's get a
little complete right I know that but
I'm just yeah we know we know we know
we're asking what it does and what it
should do and that okay so here if I say
percent 121
little evaluate
right okay so the question is this
is it
how much are we upset that it doesn't
evaluate in the association case it
would be terrible if it evaluates it
would make Association useless
because it would it would you have a
large Association that stores a lot of
data and information
if the structure if it changes or if it
needs to be traversed every single time
if there's a Content okay
it would render it useless
semantic difference here why do we think
that this corner case about about map
makes any difference given that big
semantic change
in other words are we arguing about
something that is worth arguing about or
not or is it just the case associations
work differently they are they hold
their innards because that's an
important thing for their efficiency and
that has the consequence that map
behaves differently in them yeah they do
work differently the question is do we
want to try and iron out a few of these
Fringe cases which could be done in a
reasonable way okay or do we just say
they are a consequence of the fact that
it has different semantics and I also
think there's a difference between
um this didn't evaluate but when you
look up the key then it's going to
evaluate which is which means that it
was basically just a delayed evaluation
until you needed the value so that's
fine
versus
um this thing was inside hold complete
but yet map decided to do the evaluation
anyway oh yeah that's kind of weird okay
that's the but but you know the
semantics are going to be weird relative
to what we normally have
because of this fact I mean it's it is
behaving as if okay so the one thing
which is which is visibly a bit iffy is
the fact that Association apply is doing
its business even when Association
normally doesn't have any in other words
we made the choice
right so so so let me let me let me zoom
out for a second right yes there is the
issue with you know map forcing
evaluations even inside of fold all
complete when there's an association
inside the fold all complete which you
know bites people every now and then
but you know once you know about it you
can you can deal with it
um there was this other issue that
replaced never Force develop sorry
replace all number
forced evaluation replace did sometimes
but not other times and basically for 13
3 even though this is a bit of a you
know this is definitely an incompatible
change we've decided to make replace
behave like replace all and never Force
evaluation I think that's thirteen too
I I think that I'm pretty sure that's
13-3
no you remember better than I would so
that way so we're not shipping it yet
it's basically what you're saying
correct
okay
so I mean essentially the issue here is
the only thing which seems shocking
is that
okay so normally there is evaluation
going on in values
and you're saying that even when you put
armor in there to prevent evaluation
it still manages to go inside and do the
evaluation which is a little bit
shocking yes
okay so the question is should it detect
the presence of armor what is the what
is the armor the armor is is colon grit
colon greater than or what
what is the sculpture around the
association or something
of a whole complete around the
association
oh for goodness sake I mean
oh I see
right if you said hold complete if you
said hold complete of an association
then outside of that you say map at
level two or something
and we see that the value is null as
opposed to in the list case where it
just you know wraps the
um
sorry the two print
um yeah and uh as opposed to just
wrapping the two in print like it did in
the listings okay okay I get it so so
maybe just as a question so that's yeah
and then we had this inconsistency and
you know the question is are we okay
with the resolution of just we make all
the replaced guys be consistent they
don't force evaluation because perfectly
honest when you're dealing with held
Express you know manipulating Pelt
Expressions it's much more common to use
or replace type functions than map type
functions
um look I think it's weird that map sort
of explodes on contact inside this whole
complete thing
is there a way of getting around it
right
like is there some because presumably if
it didn't evaluate
well right I mean there's some cases
where like if something doesn't evaluate
you can make it evaluate but here's a
case where it does evaluate is there any
way of stopping it
I doubt it except making it a nut making
the thing you're injecting I mean
basically what this is is you inject
this thing and it blows up inside and
you can't stop it even though the thing
is Frozen
so that's bad I admit that that's bad
right so let's come back tonight so the
only yeah the only work around right now
is to you know you map a symbol F and
then you slash dot f goes to whatever
you actually wanted
do we have other cases of forced
evaluation
even inside hold complete
the only ones I'm aware of are
Association I I won't claim that's an
exhaustive knowledge but okay well Mark
you had this proposal of maintaining the
information that you went into a hold
complete
yeah so so the recursive function that's
used by Matt goes down level by level by
level
um it would need
to see if it ever encountered you'd have
to have a uh bookkeeping of the heads of
things like whole whole complete Maybe
unevaluated
and then it would just pass around a
flag an extra parameter in the recursion
that would say I'm inside hold or
completely I mean I I retract my
statement about how horrifying that is
but let me ask a question if you do this
inside trees do we have any tree
Representatives here
great
the tree expert all right so how does
this relate to I mean how do trees
relate to associations in terms of their
uh holiness
I would say
tree trees can't have transformation
rules attached to them like Expressions
can
so like once you have a tree like
there's no need to like wrap it in hold
or anything like that
and no but but this particular issue I
mean there's a there's a a tree map
right
yeah
it evaluates everything so it's not like
map but what happens if you say hold
complete of the tree
and then you say tree map and to the
hold complete of the tree what does it
do
well
right you'd have to like map the tree
map into the actual tree portion okay so
the issue here is okay so ordinary map
does what on a tree
nothing what do you mean by nothing it
just treats the trees and treats it like
a raw expression
well as a raw expression or it's a
normal expression no I think it's a roar
expression I think it does nothing it
doesn't go inside which may be a mistake
yeah it probably treats it like an
atomic expression
I thought trees were were not raw
Expressions yeah I think they're normal
right they're normal expressions with
maybe some
extra stuff so this stood up so what the
heck did this do
well look at the full form it probably
just just wait either it's Atomic Q or
it just did something horrible to full
form yes
oh it's it's Atomic okay
it's a raw expression yeah yeah well so
that's I mean that of course would be
the way that associations could get out
of this is just say is to you know pull
the atomic flag so to speak well I think
they are Atomic Q aren't they but they
but they still let you map over them and
stuff yeah it's gonna be very bad if you
can't map over an association well right
but but wouldn't I like to be able to
map over a tree as well
but there's in their treatment
and why
why wouldn't why don't we have work
well train map allows various specs you
know in addition to actual map
specifications right it allows all sorts
of tree specific
specifications traversing order Etc
at that point I mean it's really quite
different it applies the function to the
data and evaluates that result
everywhere
all right let's okay to conclude this
segment
seems to me Mark should investigate the
possibility of doing this this flagging
I'm a little bit nervous about it but it
seems like that's the least horrifying
of the bus boxes okay
I mean there's a lot of related you know
there's all the map variants there's
scan there's you know
yeah
mechanism I doubt it I doubt it very
much
ah sigh
well Mark should do an investigation
figure out what yeah
all right on to the next item
oh my gosh this is a big item
yes I mean these are both and and it's
sort of not uh unrelated to the previous
item
um
uh
right so if you know once we actually
have uh
um right this is an ongoing conversation
um
okay but but
in this world of manipulating Health
Expressions yep
I mean the primary objective here is
various kinds of meta programming code
transformation and things like this
right
that's what we'd be like to be able to
do
um
and does this work
that's uh that's a working example right
there
the best that's that's all fine what's
what's wrong with that I'm not saying
there that that's just an example uh
uh Nick is pointing out this um
map at evaluate
which is an interesting Twist on the
whole association evaluation thing
right I mean and this is undoubtedly
just doing semi-true
um
what this is basically map at using
immediate evaluate which doesn't exist
yet but was greenlit
right so remember we talked about having
an immediate evaluate and immediate
binding
and you know some theoretical person who
has time to work on that will Implement
these
um which is part of the held expression
stack correct
right
evaluate doing the context of the
association of conversation we just had
if you replace something if you replace
that right hand side by if you did a map
which involved an immediate evaluate if
you said map immediate evaluate blah
blah blah
that first input would give you a goes
to 4 and B goes to 9.
if what if I said here if you need to
evaluate of
that pure function
like this
I think it would want to go around the
the whole function
I see so it's it's really a
right it's a tag which says rather than
just sticking in the function and
uh you know then letting the evaluator
take over Force evaluation at the moment
to stick it into the expression so this
is what apply associate Association
apply whatever it is is doing by default
we need to evaluate wrap there by
default
yep
not as heinous as it might be
okay
okay well this seems like a good
mechanism
which is I guess why we designed it
before
all right this seems like a huge topic
this held Expressions topic and it seems
like
do we is there more I mean I'd like to
make sure we make progress on the
supplied thing
okay well we can we can I think Skip
ahead to supply
okay
um right which was
um right so does this was sort of where
we left off last time which was a couple
more months ago than I would like but uh
you know here we are circling back you
wanted us to prepare a list of functions
that could benefit from uh the
contextual variables and supplied and so
much shorter list than I would have
expected
[Music]
um
it's kind of a list of lists if you look
closely yeah I know I see that
looks like they're probably like 40
functions here
you're not 40. so let's take color
function as an example
I see that could have all kinds of stuff
right so for example right now with
color function you need to go to the ref
page and look for you know for this Fizz
function
you know what the arguments are which
arguments are supplied in which order
right and it's going to be different
between plot and parametric plot and
plot 3D yeah
um and you know if we had some way of
sort of naming these things then you
could
right so not all not all values of not
all keys would make sense for all
functions right but we could have you
know family of things that you know all
the best functions yeah it's also
ambient things like the image size you
could pull in here
into color function I'm not sure I see
how that would be relevant but well I
mean let's imagine yeah well it is
actually sometimes wrong you want to
darken things that they get too small
and stuff like this
basically
so in other words right now there's no
situational awareness so to speak for
color function
it just
it only sees
the function has no way to grab things
from the outer the the color function
itself has no way to grab things from
the outer uh you know function call
but how far did we get I mean for
example with map we had we had a list of
possible variables like index and things
like this right level
Supply ref page supplied ref page
right which of course doesn't include
all of these functions this was sort of
you know you you we looked at that ref
page last time and you're like we need a
bigger list so we went out and made a
bigger list okay
has any of this stuff implemented
no
so what does it figure out now about
foreign some of it for tree map but with
a different mechanism not supplied
yeah
what did we figure out about supplied
with one argument
that you can just do it right without
the element names in the beginning
I thought we had agreed to not do a
supplied with one argument because you
for those situations you can use
contextual variables
what do you mean contextual variables
you'll have like a pure function with I
don't remember whatever things
and it just pulls in the index into your
pure function or whatever
okay what happened to the dollar dollar
Index stuff
and what's the relationship between that
and supply
we have two lists here one is things
that could use both and one is things
that could only use contextual variables
right and right the relationship is that
the
you know the contextual variables are
um
you know right they have sort of
inherent meaning whereas with supplied
right you give a mapping between
uh
you know the the things you want and
your career function because right you
may have uh right you may have a
function f
right that you want to use with supplied
and you can tell it you know first
argument is ahead and second argument is
level
I see rather than naming them
correct
and maybe another way of thinking about
is that the supplied is is not
necessarily lexical right
the contextual variables
something worries me about them
I mean so you're imagining that we do
things like we instead of map index we
would say map F of hash comma dollar
dollar Index
you know the slightly strange things
that you know
right why is there a hash and not just
dollar dollar element
if you get what I'm saying like at some
level there's no reason to even have the
function you could just have you know 10
contextual variables
but then it wouldn't be held that that
was something we discussed you could you
could literally have a f of dollar
dollar Index with no Ampersand and it
would work because
the variable in the function oh God you
know you know there's something
horrifying about this this is exactly
how SMP worked
foreign
having done this okay there was then
this notion of what what I called Marx
which were the way of getting around
not having because you have an ambiguity
okay if you have this and you say F of
index
ranged
it's very weird
that that gets lexically substituted but
that
you know this doesn't get lexically
substituted and gets wrapped
so the I think the compelling use for
them is like replace things where you
have a right hand side
well
right and he replaces how we first start
talking about them
but I think it's some of the replace
like I I don't know I I still think that
the
the use cases for functions that take
pure functions are a lot more compelling
than use cases for functions where you'd
have sort of a supplied like thing on
the right hand side of a rule
can you do the right hand side of the
rule some other way by having it on the
left somehow or something or
it just doesn't know where the rule I
mean there might be some other mechanism
for
um
you know I mean one could imagine
something where one just says you know
rural environment or something
what
blah blah blah
or maybe maybe it's on the left and it's
sort of like
uh what was that thing I mean there's a
thing we talked about about the
canonicalizing pattern and stuff like
that where the idea is you could put you
could put sort of pattern variables
inside this left-hand side thing and
those pattern variables will be bound to
all sorts of
you know all sorts of stuff so you can
imagine having like a uh I don't know
what you'd call it a localized pattern
or something it's a bad name but
position pattern of you know X under you
know X underscore comma p and p will be
bound to the position in the overall
expression where this pattern was found
what is this so
yeah it's X underscore
yeah and then and then Arrow something
rather and then the idea is that X would
be bound to the expression that this
thing is matching to and P can be bound
to whatever you want so we bounce any of
the position
I mean this is very much it's kind of an
inverse of supply
somehow right but but it's making you
it's forcing you to choose a name for
this thing right so so you know it might
be something like pattern supplied
and then one could say something like
this isn't the right syntax but
something like P colon it would just be
X not X under bar surely
whenever because presumably you can tell
it you know I I only match to an integer
right this is like pattern where on the
one side you have the symbol p and on
the other side you have the pattern that
you'd like to match to in this case x
blank
right so something like this a pattern
supplied
well I'm not sure that colon makes any
sense
right but it's naming the index is it
VAR ARG or do you have a list you might
want to do more than one I don't know I
don't know about that but but the basic
Point here is
okay so then you still have a generic
function like that though I mean
especially for for just generalized
pattern matching I can't really imagine
of many many things you'd like to supply
I mean there's the position
there's maybe the index if we're making
that distinction yeah what else
right
to be clear
well it makes one wonder about these
other
I mean here there's lots of convenience
pieces because you could argue all of
these things you could get from apart
from you can't get the negative level
from the position
but I mean which of these well how would
you how would you have something similar
I mean right when we talked about this
with like uh you know map like if you
want to basically have something like
map index but you want to be able to do
it in man
how would you do that with any similar
mechanism
like I think this is a somewhat pattern
specific thing because it's all about
binding to some variable
well I mean I assume that it's this
right that this whoops
not index oh yeah yeah right
well yes that's the unfortunate thing I
mean this would be that comma F of hash
yes
but what how do I get the expression
Hash Hash one is the expression hash two
is the position right
now
so here's here's here's what we talked
about last time so supplied of a string
you know comma function will put the
main argument in hash one and we'll put
the string mentioned value so position
here in hash two if you give it a list
of strings though then that list will
correspond to the arguments of that
right so you would say you know quotes
you know argument comma quotes position
comma quotes whatever and those would
correspond to Hash one through n
which does mean that Supply the list
position is different from supplied of
just position that makes sense yeah
which is okay
so it reminds me a little bit to
understand after the F what's that
you're missing an ampersand
off to the f
okay right I would say the strength of
supplied is that you can just put a
symbol F there and Define it somewhere
else
right
okay
and then the alternative that we'd
imagine which I think is is semantically
a bit horrifying is the idea of having
instead of that
having F of this comma dollar dollar
Index
got that so like SMP
that's not it I I agree that's not the
supplied is a much is a much cleaner
Design This is a little bit like
adorning a function to give a different
type
so we we don't have types of functions
but you could imagine if we had
you know choosing a function of a
different type picking up different
arguments to pass in picking up a
different version of Mac
saying that yeah I mean this is some
kind of polymorphism that you know
rapper yes yes I think that's that's
good it's like function function
oriented and polymorphic I think that's
clean
well what it's doing is it is supplying
I mean I have to say this name's
supplied we keep on referring to it as
supplied which means this probably isn't
a bad name
we spend a long time thinking of other
possible names but I don't think this
name is terrible
um
so
let's see so I mean the the semantics
here
I really think this will work something
like this whether whether it's this here
which has a resonance with the supplied
concept
I think the pattern Supply you have
there really doesn't make any sense
why at least the way you've written it
well both because of the thing of I'm
not sure you know what you want other
than position but but also I mean
the way you've written it the P colon
index means a position that matches
quotes index it doesn't it really
doesn't feel like a rule I mean another
thing by the way that presumably you
could write if we supported this thing
although it would make it a little more
complicated is instead of writing P you
could presumably write a pattern and it
would only match things you know it
would only that pattern will be applied
to the position so it would only match
things at a position that matches that
pattern if that makes sense but then
that then that P would need to be a p
blame right I'm sorry yeah I'm this
isn't quite as silly as I think you're
claiming that it is what I'm claiming is
that this P colon index just like you
can say x colon blank means the matching
is for blank the name is X
this is saying the matching is with the
x-blank the name you're binding another
name it's peace
it's like bind
right but the colon like pattern the
colon there I think it's a pattern
construct it's not something you know
and it means something it has a string
on the right
right
all right I agree that's a reasonable it
could be a key in an association
yeah or an arrow would be better than
yeah
right
maybe it could be I mean is there a
reason it shouldn't be P blank actually
I mean it would make the implementation
a bit more complicated
that that would be for position pattern
right yeah for position pattern you'd
write you'd explain comma P blank I see
which means it matches any position
is
yeah
that's nice because because among other
things you could then expect to have
something which we absolutely cannot do
right now which is you know slash
semi-length the P less than whatever it
is
sure yeah
that's a nice construct
right that you actually sort of can do
using
uh using uh like replace and the level
specification but you couldn't do say
you know first of p is greater than two
and less than seven
right or or like oh the the you know
every other argument of the P has to be
a two or something like that right
this is nice this is a good idea
but that's I like this
okay so let's see how this would then go
along with
I mean how many of these things here
which are part of supplied
you know okay so the point here is there
are lots of potential other things this
came up in trees where they're just lots
of other potential environmental
variables that you would want to
consider
yep
this is a good construct this position
perfect
I like that
um I'm not sure sorry I was just
glancing at the rough page and there was
something like position and current
position which
I'm not sure I understood
right there's position and current
position and I don't know what I am
about this out it may not even make
sense but the idea is the position
refers to the position in the original
expression but if you're changing the
expression then you're also changing the
positions you don't know you've changed
it yet because the thing what map is
doing is just filling in structural
stuff and it's then going to evaluate it
there's no way it can know
that's for the future
well it doesn't matter like at multiple
levels doesn't it go from the bottom up
like I was thinking about this
originally for trees where you might do
like a breadth first and yeah if you're
I see yeah I'd be shoving the rest of
the tree down into deeper levels as
you're doing it but I I don't know all
right Daddy but supplied
I mean I think I think we should
implement it you know we should start
trying to implement supplied
I I don't think the dollar dollar Index
thing is a is a good idea okay
I mean what do other people think well
you know that I was skeptical of it from
the beginning
was I a big enthusiast
uh yes
so we're doing position pattern and
supply
that's what I'm thinking
but let's think for a second I mean you
know the only thing that's bad about
supplied is how long on ponderous syntax
is
foreign
although
um
and it still maybe has the pseudo
problem that in the actual body of the
function you still call them hash one
and hash two instead of something like
hash
position which might be more readable
yeah which might be much more readable
I don't think we know how to do that and
I think it'll be much better if in the
end okay so I mean this will be
magnificent if this could be made to
work
um
something like that could be made to
work and I think that was the original
original thing we talked about but it
was kind of deemed a bit too magical
well I mean it would clearly be
unmagic if there was the following piece
of semantics which I think is probably
insane
okay if this this this is insane
probably
well it's multiple levels of magic It's
Magic because you have hash and hash
position It's Magic because you have uh
uh cash position but you haven't told it
what keys you want so it has to be able
to lexically look and see the position
of the only one you use and it's magic
because ideally you wouldn't want to
construct an association for each
iteration
right
I mean
yeah right
okay so taken
I know double M side is taken that's
where I've got a space
uh
um
I mean the question is is there any
lexical mechanism
I mean
there's nothing wrong with this except
for the fact that it's hard to type
and to understand when you see it in
code
which
and it also seems really wrong to have
this hash versus
I mean look of how you can have function
and wrap the variables and typed
there you you wrap the type closely with
the variable that you're using it with
foreign
well the other possibility would be
something like this
where you always one of the magic
problems but but not the other two
well I mean this could be
where's the Ampersand here
presumably inside supplied yes and after
the F yep
right so we could imagine this as a one
argument form right I was going to point
out that the what you input you have two
lines above doesn't make any sense I
mean that's not something that you could
ever no it could never work yeah
right
yeah but I guess maybe supplied could
just you know instead of map having to
to look at its peer function supplied
could just look and it's one argument
form and it could do crazy stuff to
manipulate
slots and so on
well I could turn this into supplied
could turn this up that's what I mean it
would evaluate to
to the version to the to the spread out
version
foreign
this could actually transform the funk
this could matter program essentially
the the function in here and actually
turn this into
and at least that way it localizes all
the crazy slot manipulation to be inside
supplied instead of something like map
having to
you know
17 variants
exactly yes
this doesn't seem crazy to me this is a
perfectly readable thing
yep I I agree I I would I would I I have
no objection to this one argument form
yeah I like it
and that way so in this particular case
there would never be magic with hash one
right no hash one magic
right you don't get a default if you're
using this if you're using the one
argument form of supplied you have to
specify
the name of every argument that you want
yeah
I think we should see whether we can
move forward with this I think these two
ideas position pattern and this
Supply both seem pretty reasonable for
me there's no there's no absurd magic
here the only absurd magic is you have
to look up for every function what
parameters does it Supply to supplied
yeah
okay while we're on a roll very quick
look at this is this easy or is this
horrifyingly hard
um
it's it's uh a little detailed
um I I wouldn't describe it as easy
um
right now but I mean just in in rough
terms
this is this is the stuff that I've been
wanting where
I want to be able to I mean what are the
things do we have a good list of what we
want to be able to do
I mean this is the thing I want to be
able to Echo
as a debug thing and have it clean up
after itself
right and right so you had this whole
slew of things and I wasn't convinced by
all of the names and even the utilities
look the basic point is
there a lot of these things now where we
have a progress monitor
it comes up while you're running
interactively it's very useful to be
able to see but it doesn't stay when
it's finished it goes away when it's
finished
I find that flow very nice
am I making sense
well well uh you know you've said
something so innocuous you you couldn't
offended an MP with it uh
right okay
okay I mean it's not obvious that okay
but I'm saying that's nice so the point
with Echo is we don't have a way to do
that we don't have a way
I mean it makes me think that the right
thing to do is to have an overall
wrapper okay so
um
let's say
it's called Echo collector
or Echo panel
let's say
uh you called it I think pan that Echo
last time
no but that's the thing that's slightly
different right so I will say we did
discuss having like a super like Echo
Handler function and decided that we
liked the composability of these
several like but but
what I'm suggesting here is Echo
collector is something you put outside
of everything
and it just packages up all of the echo
stuff
and puts it in some kind of temporary
panel
uh-huh that's exactly what I think panel
Echo
does
except that maybe the the
well okay yeah I guess I I was just
thinking that panel Echo I guess sounds
a little bit like good
yeah I mean I wasn't thrilled with the
name I'm just saying but the point of
echo collector will be this normally if
you just run expert you'd see a bunch of
Echoes on the screen
okay
Echo collector would essentially just
like sort of an old-fashioned Unix pipe
redirector
would take all those Echoes and put them
in a panel
so they clean up after themselves in
other words you know let's say you're
doing this let's say that you are
you've made something and you've got a
few Echoes and you start putting more
Echoes In and you kind of don't want to
see and you want to control those Echoes
better
but you don't want to have to think for
every single Echo how do I want to
control this the idea here will be you
just put an outer Echo collector or Echo
Handler and it decides what to do
because I think we were we were running
into trouble with
you know by the time we've got Max Echo
limits and it's limit Echo and so on and
so on and so on it just seems like
the typical thing is you've put Echoes
In
hmm
somehow you're getting too many echoes
but sometimes okay look here's another
case there's another case you've got a
piece of code you don't know if it's
ever going to be hit
okay
but it turns out it's hit 10 000 times
you really don't want to see that you
just want to see the first you know like
like I mean our message limiting
mechanism is fairly good in that regard
stood the test of time quite well
right because what you don't want to see
is just blah blah blah blah blub you
know tens of thousands of error messages
you want to see the diversity of
messages so to speak you want to see oh
it's a new and different message that
started coming out
and arguably so is it with echoes
but again it's not clear whether you
want a locally limit Echoes whether you
want a globally limit echoes
sounds to me like this is a separate
discussion
no they'll just I'll I'll just say
really quickly that in terms of you know
thinking about the name
uh
instead of thinking about the the GUI
that's inside of you know I this feels a
bit to me like you know a news feed or a
stock ticker or something like that and
there might be something in that concept
that we can draw a name from
yes yeah yeah you'll notice that one of
my points is that Pat you know you
suggested the name panel Echo last time
which was you know we aren't selecting a
jury here so this is just the wrong name
I I think Stephen suggested ticker tape
Echo before I might be misremembering
yeah I think we've um
um
I mean we certainly had the
right and and sort of one of the
questions uh that's worth uh you know
thinking about is does this thing just
collect the content or also the dingbats
because
you know in some cases the thing for
some types of Echoes the thing bats
carry
useful information cool the timing okay
timing and things like this
I'm sure it has to collect the dingbats
as well a question here is what is the
connection between this and the error
handling world
is there one
and is there are there Echoes that
should contain drillable stuff like a
stack trace for example
like you know I consider our
stack trace on messages really quite
successful I don't know how other people
feel about that
well I find it useful whenever I turn
off the
uh
the uh what's it called the the
filtering that's done by default because
usually
I have a different meeting that I was
supposed to go to here I I probably
should disappear to that
um okay well we can take this up next
time
all right thanks a lot guys see you
later